ever wonder why leonard from the big
bang theory puts up with sheldon howard
and rogers non-stop shenanigans keep
watching to see the theory behind the
zany characters theatrics leonard
hofstadter and sheldon cooper on the big
bang theory were roommates for most of
the 12 years the hit series was on the
air the two first met when leonard
answered sheldon's ad for a roommate
which leonard soon learned would also
mean driving him to and from work having
to drive sheldon proves the least of
leonard's worries however how does he
keep coming up with new ways to be
annoying
[Music]
nobody knows that's why he's number one
he soon finds out that sheldon is highly
neurotic stubborn and difficult in fact
leonard is required to sign a roommate
agreement before sheldon even considers
him if that's not a huge red flag then
we honestly don't know what qualifies
throughout the series sheldon cites the
agreement and it's often ridiculous
clauses when he thinks leonard is
stepping out of line there's a big
inspection coming up and i don't want to
lose my tv privileges
you really need to let me take a look at
that roommate agreement one of these
days
because living with sheldon is such a
chore lynyrd has compared his friend to
a first pet that could ruin your life
many have wondered why leonard puts up
with him some have suggested that
perhaps luna seeks validation from
emotionally withholding people having
grown up with a mother who is
essentially a female version of sheldon
maybe that upbringing fuels a desire to
take care of someone so he can feel he
is doing something right the
psychological take does make sense but
there's one reddit user among the active
fan community with a different tape
leonard is actually being paid by the
university to look after its genius
employee a user posed the theory to
reddit the idea came to them during an
episode where raj is skyping with his
family back home in india it is
mentioned that the caltech employees
have limited earning potential implying
that they receive less than desirable
incomes if their earning potential
really is limited then how do leonard
and sheldon pay for rent comics laptops
and other nerdy goods the user explains
my theory is that the university is
paying leonard extra to keep an eye on
sheldon howard and raj the user came to
this conclusion given the personalities
and actions of the other three in the
show in addition to howard's reckless
behavior and raj's fear of police and
being sent back to india sheldon seems
to be unable to grasp simple concepts
and thus cannot see that his choices and
actions are wrong something's wrong with
me
i told you if we were patient he'd
figure it out for himself
if this theory holds any truth it begs
the question how are they still employed
well the user answers that too sheldon
raj and howard are geniuses probably
some of the best the university has seen
perhaps the head of the school is
desperate to hold on to them and knows
the only way to do that is to keep them
out of trouble enter leonard who is
arguably the most practical of his
foursome the user proposes leonid was
hired to carry out research and watch
over and protect these simple-minded men
another question we have to ask is why
leonard would agree to such a task after
all it's clear in the context of the
series that living with sheldon is far
from easy when one considers the theory
however it does make some sense brown
rice not wine yes you stop the korean
grocery and get the good hot mustard yes
you pick up low-sodium soy sauce from
the market yes good see how it's done
leonard
if leonard has limited earning potential
then he has to be prudent when it comes
to his money and that leaves little room
for the nerdy lifestyle we often see the
characters indulging in it would be near
impossible to afford such a nice
apartment in pasadena go to steward's
comic store nearly every other day
attend conventions and buy any pop
culture merchandise when this strange
assignment came up leonard was probably
hesitant but when he realized he didn't
have to worry about choosing between
keeping a roof over his head or being a
geek it was a simple decision of course
it must be extremely stressful having to
deal with his friends and their
shenanigans but as leonard slips under
the covers with an issue of a rare comic
he probably couldn't otherwise afford
it's surely worth it however this
plausible explanation is not without its
detractors as some people argued on
reddit raj comes from a well-to-do
family possibly skewing the meeting of
limited earning potential meanwhile
sheldon appears to save a substantial
amount of money possibly suggesting the
pay is just fine check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]